es una reunión en la casa blanca entre
socios tradicionales también celebran el
año número 70 de lealtad desde el final
de la guerra de Corea
es un vínculo inquebrantable forjado en
la valentía el sacrificio de nuestro
pueblo santificado por la sangre de las
tropas estadounidenses y coreanas que
lucharon y defendieron la libertad
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden y el de Corea del Sur y un
superior conversaron el miércoles con el
objetivo de colaborar en la disuasión de
la escalada nuclear de Corea del Norte
aumenta la ansiedad por el creciente
arsenal de misiles y bombas del
norcoreano Kim jong-un con pruebas en el
mar del Japón que se están llevando a
cabo un ritmo récord
los intentos de alterar el statu quo por
la fuerza la fragmentación y la
interrupción de la cadena de suministro
así como los retos en materia de
seguridad alimentaria energética
amenazan la paz y la estabilidad mundial
de yuna Estados Unidos también se
produce pocas semanas después de la
filtración de documentos clasificados
del pentágono que ha complicado las
relaciones con los aliados
estadounidenses incluida Corea del Sur
sin embargo en un movimiento diseñado
para restaurar la confianza los líderes
han firmado un acuerdo conocido como la
declaración de Washington como parte del
acuerdo Estados Unidos desplegará varios
submarinos nucleares a Corea del Sur por
primera vez en cuatro décadas mientras
que la creación de un grupo consultivo
Estados Unidos Corea del Sur dará a seúl
una mayor voz en la política nuclear